[Music]
let's finally review Plato there
Republic why am I doing this how did I
go from Ukraine it's cringe for you me
to even bring it up but like I used to
scream at horror games anyway I'm new to
philosophy and I have always been told
that I should always start with the
Greeks and no thank you i always say i
would rather read there
but finally I picked up Plato's
symposium because it was fairly short
and I thought why not but I was very
happily surprised it was very good it
felt like looking through a window of
time where you joined the dinner table
of ancient Greek philosophers discussing
through the night there are thoughts on
eros their desires and it was very nice
so naturally led me to read one to read
the Republic which is arguably Plato's
greatest work if not one of the greatest
political western philosophies of all
time what a title everyone and again I
was very happily surprised how much I
enjoyed it for those who don't know it's
a it's a dialectic it's a dialogue
between two people or a couple people
with different views and somehow coming
to some form of conclusion and I find
this style of writing to be so much more
engaging and immersing seem like I
described with the symposium Plato's
writing is about coming to a conclusion
together and Plato himself
self-admittedly doesn't have all the
answers that's why I picked this book
because I think it could be interesting
to discuss because of all of these
things that I just said how do I make
videos sorry this will be a very long
video but that's strap on and put on
your vlog seatbelts and let's freakin do
this please keep watching I need the
watch time just put put on the video in
the background I don't care just keep we
have some couple important notes before
we begin Plato the Republic is a very
controversial piece of literature it
challenges fundamental ideas not just
around society but also how we review
our own lives in ways that might feel a
bit uncomfortable it probably should
make you feel uncomfortable and I think
that's a lot of times the point as a way
to challenge ideas I don't know if
that's true or not I just threw that in
there but most importantly I just want
to say here early on big disclaimer I do
not agree with every single idea that
this author has a necessary 20:19
disclosure everyone
I think most people wouldn't agree with
all the ideas of Plato and Plato himself
doesn't agree with all his ideas so we
get later on he'll disc criticize his
own thoughts basically I am NOT an
expert I am not pretending that I know
everything about this I will just give
my own summary and thoughts around the
different topics discussed and I highly
encourage you to do your own study and
research to fully get that proper grasp
of this book this is going great
first of all I think it's important to
understand why this book was written to
fully understand where the ideas came
from to properly critique something you
you need more than just the ideas you
need to understand where the ideas come
from and a lot of the more crazy ideas
of Plato that a republic will make a lot
more sense with these things in mind I
think at least so some quick background
basically Plato lived in 428 did I get
that right that's right
428 BC in Athens Greek in Greece Greece
Athens and the ancient Greek as I'm sure
a lot of you are already familiar with
defined a lot of our Western
civilization babe had massive leaps in
not just philosophy but our literature
biology architecture politics and much
much more
all this while simultaneously fighting
two wars the Persian War and the
Peloponnesian War this has relevance we
will get there I promise just keep the
video going in the background so during
the Persian War where the Greeks were
vastly outnumbered I always imagined
like the movie 300 even though that's
clearly not what happened at all but the
Greeks were vastly outnumbered but the
way they defeat the Persians was from
coming together all the different
city-states of greece came together
ancient greece back then was
very different from how we know brief is
it Greek or Greece it's really annoying
me how I don't know this it was very
different from what it is today it's
been north and I think even across Italy
all these different areas I don't know
exactly the their Geographics okay but
it was bigger okay and the old estates
came together and just be like no Persia
go away and they did it but after this
word after defeating the Persians
instead of all the states coming
together they broke apart and they
fought against each other in a civil war
known as the Peloponnesian War where
they fought against who should be the
ruler of the city-states it was a very
it was a very brutal war which you can
tell just from how long it lasted 27
years and eventually Athens lost play to
live who lived during this time he saw
the effects of this war he people close
to him that passed away and I think and
I think keeping this in mind is
important for some of the more crazy
ideas that are proposed in the Republic
because Plato wanted to avoid civil war
at all cost and I think keeping that in
mind is important to have an open eye
open mind for the discussion
the second reason I think is because
Athens at this time was a democracy and
that was something that the Athenians
were very proud of it's something that
was part of their character that they
had that they lived in a democracy and
it was something that they greatly
upheld but in 399 BC 399 so Cortez I'll
never forget that number so Curtis the
philosopher was executed under this
democracy and I think this is something
that really affected Plato and also
shaped ideas for the Republic so the
Peloponnesian War and the fact that
Socrates was executed I don't know if
this is correct
I'm just saying okay so then what was
Plato's and Socrates relationship we
haven't even started with the book
review yet Felix
this is just an essay at this point I
just think it's necessary to establish
early on why their relationship I didn't
really know it I mean I think most
people have heard of so Curtis
maybe not of Plato or vice versa I don't
know but so cthis was a philosopher he
is a historical figure that that did
exist the thing is that he never wrote
down any of his work and it was Plato
who basically did this but Plato writes
his work in the Republic as a dialogue
where Socrates is the main character and
obviously we can't know for sure to what
level of accuracy the dialogue actually
occurred most likely it wasn't that
accurate but again we don't know but it
is a little bit confusing because Plato
is the author and but Socrates is the
main character who presents all these
ideas some compare Socrates and played
this relationship as a sort of
teacher-student relationship which is
inaccurate because so Kurt has never
taught he'd spoken people listened but
it also kind of fits the picture as well
I like to see it as a senpai and kohai
kind of relationship so then what is the
Republic about you might ask how long
have I recorded Oh God
well Socrates is famously not interested
in finding relative solutions he wants
to find absolute truths if we don't know
what something is then how can we
properly understand it and so curtis is
famous for trapping his opponents with
his what is it question to give it give
a definition of something and the
Republic begins with such a question
such a what is it question in Brooke one
the novel begins with Socrates he is
walking home from a religious festival
and he stumbles into some acquaintances
who convinced him to come over to their
place he sort of half reluctantly
accepts there's a couple of people in
this group but let's focus on cephalus
first syphilis is an older man and the
dialogue begins with this what is it
question coming from a soccer test who
as cephalus what's it like to be so old
this could be seen as a very rude
question to ask someone but Socrates
once to spark a conversation not about
making people feel good
despite the very rude question cephalus
responds in a composed manner of saying
that well I enjoy being old I no longer
feel controlled by arrows my desires
doesn't control him anymore he looked
forward to being rewarded in his next
life because he's lived an honest life
and lived up to his legal dues so he
thinks well I may be old I may be dying
soon but I still will be rewarded in the
next life and Socrates goes godom you
just gave me a definition of justice
living in an honest life and living up
to your legal dues that's the definition
of justice that you just gave me even
though that's not my question
and then to stomp over settle his
argument that he never even
intentionally made Socrates challenges
cephalus view England further and says
well if justice is living up to your
legal dues then let's say for example I
don't know if this is not the example he
brings but let's say you borrow an axe
from a friend because you need to chop
some wood and then later on your friend
demands to have the axe back but the
friend has gone completely insane
would you still give the axe back to him
obviously not you you wouldn't give a
weapon to a crazy person so in that's
regard no justice is not living up to
your legal obligations and you are just
wrong in this argument that you never
even made cephalus who's old is not
interested in this conversation and he
bids his farewell and leaves the group
but there are some younger remaining
people in the group who has been
listening and they give their opinion on
instead one of them being Chris amicus
who is a sawfish Sophists were teachers
I think back in ancient Greek where they
would be hired by rich people to teach
their sons they are the enemy of Plato
and Socrates you can say because they
are not interested in finding absolute
truth and they're just more interested
in winning an argument basically and go
into whatever stretched to do so
so there's images this office says gives
his definition of justice and says
justice is the advantage of the stronger
he admits that this is not really a
definition but he's saying that it pays
off more to be unjust than to be just
and people who are are unjust naturally
progress in society and justice is a
restraint put on us stopping our natural
desires to progress Socrates then
responds by saying well if justice is in
the advantage of the stronger do people
make mistakes and through simcha says
yes people make mistakes and then
Socrates asked well-to-do rulers make
mistakes and of course recent mexico
says yes rulers can make mistakes and
then he finishes by saying well I don't
remember if this is the exact example
but let's say for example if you are a
ruler and you put up a tax policy that
will benefit you you will get more money
from the people and you'll raise the
taxes but the ruler is doing what they
think is just because they have the
advantage and they gain from this but
let's say then that this new tax policy
basically bleeds the city dry there's no
more money left and eventually it will
end up hurting the ruler because he's
left with less than what he had from the
beginning and you know
longer acquire anything from its
citizens therefore justice is not in
fact in the advantage of the stronger
because rulers makes mistakes through
Simic has response then by saying well I
need to win this argument justice is
what the ruler thinks is in the
advantage of the stronger and very
interestingly their Simba cos sort of
just disappears from the book at this
point he could very well still be part
of the group and listening silently but
it's not worthy how he disappears at
this point because he brings up the
subject he brings up the the relative
argument and so Curtis just isn't
interesting interested in it that's not
the reason of this dialogue he wants to
find the ultimate troop of what is
justice Socrates has now defeated his
opponents more or less but the rest of
the group is not entirely satisfied
golovkin who is another member of the
party wants a better definition of
justice is just life superior to an
unjust life it's a question that they
ask and they want Socrates to prove it
and maybe you were thinking while
finding the definition of justice that's
really not that interesting at least
first when I heard about it I wasn't
completely engaged but when you think
about it and a broad broad sense it it
really shapes everything in our lives
what is good and what is bad what is
right and wrong is being it's being just
better than being unjust why should you
live an unjust life instead of an unjust
life I think it's a very interesting
topic that I've never asked myself
before and gakuen brings up a very
interesting example
kokom says that justice is social bond a
contract between people which I think
can make sense he expressed as much like
her Simic has said that we have a
natural desire to wanting to gain more
and the only reason we don't act unjust
is because we don't want unjust things
happened to ourselves and if the whole
world acted unjust then everyone would
just stand to lose from it so therefore
it's a social contract his view of
Justice so therefore in his view justice
comes from weakness and it comes from
fear and he brings up this example of
the ring of guy G's which is a magical
ring so he brings up this thought
example of if you had a ring that could
render you invisible
would you still act just I think I've
played around with this idea and maybe
you have as well where if you had
something where if you could do
something unjust and no one would know
about it
would you do it and Glaucon argues that
anyone with this ring even the most just
person would still act unjust because if
you're invisible no one will know about
it you could rot rob a bank or you could
I don't know and do all kinds of things
I'm not gonna bring up their example
whenever people ask me what my
superpower ability would be I always
thought okay well what superpower could
I get that would benefit me the most and
not face any consequences so I think
this definition fits in pretty well and
I think it fits in with actually what a
lot of people look at justice it's a
pretty I think a common common way to
look at it but we may maybe we've never
actually thought about it
Edda man just join us into the
conversation as well with who is
glaucon's brother I think and he says
that justice itself isn't desirable and
that we only act just because we want to
be rewarded in the afterlife
so therefore element is in Vulcan want
Socrates to prove to them that justice
in itself is desirable and that living a
just life is better than living in a
unjust life and Socrates warns Adam
enticing glaucon that this is gonna be a
very long journey to get through and I
will warn you in case you made it this
far in this video that yes in fact it
will be very long video but they are up
for the task they're young and they're
excited and they
they want to find the answer I also
think it's interesting how Socrates
purposely wanted to hear everyone else's
argument at this point he hasn't really
expressed his own views he's literally
he's actually just picked apart what
other people's ideas are but this is
really where the book begins all of its
own topic to find the definition of
justice and the way Plato or Socrates
does this I think it's very surprising
and very interesting to prove that
justice is superior he brings up the
analogy of the human in a macro
perspective of a city it's called the
city Sol analogy and basically it means
that to prove that a just city is
happier than an unjust City the same
analogy can be drawn between a just man
and an unjust man what a just man is
happier than an unjust person and so
begins the very long journey of the
Republic I will brush through some
points just to save time and I also
still don't understand all of it to be
honest I guess I'm just too old
so to craft this society so curtis says
that each person in this city must
specialized to maximize the efficiency
of the city he wants a shoemaker to
focus solely on making shoes a doctor to
solely focus on
doing doctor things and that a shoemaker
who specializes will always be better
than a shoemaker that doesn't specialize
and the shoemaker will always be better
at making shoes then a doctor can make
shoes and a doctor will always be a
better doctor than a shoemaker ok I
think you understand what I mean so this
city will initially just start off with
farmers craftsmen doctors the city will
live with just what is necessary and and
won't go beyond that and Socrates calls
that this city is healthy because of
this but how come however has a very
different view on it he says that this
is he calls it a city of pigs ironically
he thinks that people have a natural
desire for more people have a natural
desire for luxury better entertainment
better food so he argues that they will
want to eat meat in this city which is a
seemingly small distinction from what
the city previously has been but it
makes all the difference because to have
meat in the city you need more land and
to have more land you need to go to war
and therefore they both agree that this
is a natural progression Glaucon and
socrates agrees this is a natural
progression and that war is inevitable
in this city and therefore a new class
of people is introduced in the Republic
which is the Warriors by socrates idea
of specialization warriors can only be
warriors and nothing else and he
describes his highly spirited individual
and these highly spirited individuals
make for great warriors but they are
hard to control you want to be able to
control them so they don't become thugs
and break the laws but you also don't
want them to become too wimpy as well so
Socrates proposes that the best way to
contain these warriors is through
education so it's important that these
warriors are educated to act on the will
of the city how do we do that well so
Curtis explains what stories will be
available in this city and what stories
won't be available I think more
importantly he says that the classic
legends of Homer will be forbidden or
send
third in the city because the stories in
Homer and other works show that dying as
something really bad and that's not
beneficial for the city Warriors needs
to be able to die for their state and
therefore they cannot allow that these
work of fiction to be shaping the souls
of the Warriors so Christine goes
through in great detail what will be
allowed not just in literature but also
music what kind of instrument and even
what type of notes will be allowed or at
least what will be the most effective
you can look at it the same way of the
type of music that is played in in
military it's very similar with the
drums and then the type of tunes but
this all falls under a very interesting
topic of censorship it's something that
we've all been affected by ever since
growing up our parents censor certain
things from us when we are children and
they do this for a good cause they do it
to protect us and I would argue that so
Curtis sees the city and its people in
the same way where the city would be a
mother censoring certain things for
their child censorship is a topic that
is still widely discussed even today I
think there's three points that can be
brought up against censorship I mean III
myself has been highly affected by it I
would would even say I think the number
one point against censorship is that
there's a natural curiosity towards
things that aren't allowed I think most
people can relate to wanting to do
something more because they weren't
allowed to do it and and the desire to
wanted to do it Eve being even stronger
because of it another example could be
if a parent for example lies to their
child let's say a parent a mother might
be a such a bad example if a mother is a
stripper and maybe they don't want their
child to go through go through the same
career path then they might lie about
what their job is before they go to work
it
they might say I'm going to I don't know
the bank instead to protect their child
they do this to protect their child
because they don't want them to follow
the same path but eventually let's say a
couple of years down the line the child
finds out the truth and this sort of
trust between a mother and a child has
been broken because of their censorship
and maybe the damage would have been the
damage of that is much more than what
would have been if the parent had just
said the truth a lot of times you could
argue it's the negative effect of what's
being censored really more than what is
positive just video games really cause
violence and I think by censorship you
are in playing that you know better you
know for a fact that this needs to be
censored because I know it has a
negative effect and I think that's a lot
of times is said without much evidence I
think it's a really interesting topic
some people are arguing that censorship
is good some people arguing that it's
always bad and here we are
2000 year later still discussing it
there's also many examples of in history
of progression of humanity being held
back because of censorship
we had Galileo a famous example must be
getting tired at this point whose
famously his ideas were censored because
he challenged the Christian view what's
your right what's your opinion of
censorship are you still with me hello
the next topic of the Republic is
another controversial idea in this city
that Socrates describes there will be
doctors of course but these doctors will
not treat anyone if you get wounded in
battle of course the doctor will treat
you but any form of self-inflicted
injury
will not be taken care of let's say if
you injure yourself from eating or
drinking too much as an example sorry
that time and resources will not be
wasted on you which kind of makes sense
a little bit but then it gets a little
darker so Curtis would probably argue
for a euthanasia if you have a chronic
illness you are then just costing this
city a bunch of money and resources and
therefore you will be thanked for your
service in the city but you will also be
pissed
I think obviously now we have a very
different view of life and I'm not
saying I agree with it we obviously we
know a lot more than we did back then we
don't have the same view of the
afterlife as well but I think what's
interesting here is the distinction
between a good and a bad like a
fundamental belief from when we're
grown-up is that everyone is born equal
and we have the same should be we should
all be treated equally and I agree with
that of course but I think we're I think
it's interesting is if the distinction
between a good and a bad life and I
think we treat all life as good when
that's not necessarily the case I hope
that isn't taken in a weird way by
anyone all right let's move on this is
too controversial
the third controversial idea three in a
row is the the myth of metals which is
another idea proposed by Socrates and he
explains this in the almost embarrassed
manner he knows how ridiculous this
sounds is metal metals but basically
it's a lie told by the city to its
citizens that they don't have any mother
or father and that they came from the
earth that's right and I I think the
purpose of this is pretty obvious it's
so that you would look at this state as
your parent and Socrates finds is very
useful for the sake of
hey patriotic view of the state and and
loyalty to the state and there's similar
ideas around housing people should live
together in this common areas instead of
and private households will not be
allowed by anyone even its rulers so
there's some pretty crazy ideas being
proposed here it's like Plato created
communism not Karl Marx but perhaps the
silliest bit out of the myth of metals
which is that everyone is born not just
from the earth but into different
categories so you will be born either
there into bronze silver or gold
category and depending on that which
will determine what sort of job and what
group in
society you fit into and now at this
point you might think well this sounds
pretty awful I don't want to live in
this city and neither should anyone and
I think you're right to assume that the
whole concept of this city is not with
the mindset of the well-being of certain
individuals it's it's the mindset of the
well-being of the whole state and I
think it's pretty interesting how
completely opposite our ideas around
individuality is today and there's
obviously good cause for that and good
reason for that but I think there's
examples of today of individual focus
that almost seem comical there's a lot
of famous dystopian x' written around
this sort of ideas I think we have
dystopian novels such as 1984 brave new
world we buy as a mutant who may have
inspired all of these and these were
authors who lived to see the effect of
communism and to tell it to tell it
arianism and probably written as a
reaction to that we have brave new world
which really fits into the Socratic idea
of the myth of metals where all the
people in this novel are born from tests
and labs they don't have a mother or
father they they they are born in this
Factory and you they also fit into these
groups as well they are born into this
different ranked groups in society and
everyone is happy with being part of
their own group Big Brother of course
also with the idea of the state being
this family figure almost I don't know
if that really fits but you understand
my point we we attend where there is no
individualism you are born as a number
and as the name implies itself it's oh
it's all about the group and not your
your own well-being basically according
to Socrates there will be no money in
this city which is a very interesting
topic in itself as well I Dementors he
loves goals he sees is that something
preposterous and he says that if there's
no gold then people won't the city won't
be able to defend itself because no one
will come to its aid if they can't pay
them but Socrates claims that any
neighbouring city will happily come to
its aid because they have obviously the
best warriors I've completely skipped a
part about how they grow how they train
their warriors it's very interesting but
since they have the best warriors that
doesn't care about money there will be
everything left after the battle to
plunder for themselves
since this city does not permit it I
think Socrates recognizes that money is
not necessarily a good but it's also not
necessarily something bad here we go
again with boohoo millionaire complaints
about money that's not the case I think
I view it in a very similar way I think
money is good if you spend it well but
it's not as if I have a pile of money at
home that I worship and that that in
itself brings me joy when you have money
you worry about losing money and saying
you can take for example anyone at the
stock market it seems like a very
stressful profession and I think a lot
of people have the view that if only
they had money then then they would be
happy but there's so many examples of
people winning the lottery and then
turning up more unhappy than they used
to be because their whole worldview has
changed in their whole whole life have
changed because of month I think there's
even a
science and that data behind this now
showing that after a certain point of
money you you don't become more happy
because probably implies more troubles
which I can agree with more money no
problem he said it the best
or was it biggie yeah another
interesting topic around this as well as
its expansionism where socrata says this
city will not expand beyond a certain
point because by limiting the size of
this city they can make sure that it can
maintain its ruling there's so many
examples of in history of we had
Napoleon the the constant expanding
eventually leading to its demise and I
think the same thing ties in with gold
as well when you have when you have it
you just want more and more of it
eventually leading to your own
destruction Here I am making videos
why now we're on book five everyone
I haven't mentioned this but basically
there's ten books of that Republic but
they can sort of be seen as chapters
instead and it gets even more strange at
this point
Socrates brings up the topic of
selective procreation where another
great light that will be told by the
state which is that everyone's partner
will be determined through a lottery
state lottery where basically your
sexual partner it's completely by chance
or so they are will be told of course
the state will instead put together the
most desirable or admirer below that
they want more of in this city to breed
the best kind of people in the city and
also avoid any form of incest because
obviously people don't know who their
real mothers and fathers are so it's
also necessary for that sense I think
they follow the same storyline in we
said yet and savvy Athens we
where everyone has their set partner in
this dystopia I think it's interesting
how they bring up this topic for nearly
2000 years ago of genetics and and their
and reproducing we're getting to a point
where we'll in the future most likely be
able to I think I read in an in another
book where people I think it was Stephen
Hawking actually he pointed out how
people with will eventually manipulate
the DNA so that this superior people
will come into existence we can we can
change DNA in a way that we can craft
certain individuals for certain purposes
and Socrates was playing with the idea
even 2,000 years ago I think that's
interesting in book five as well we get
to hear a little bit of Plato's ideas
around feminism which is not the best
way to put it
I don't think I think most people don't
think that Socrates or Plato had any
sort of ideas we have today but he
recognizes that men and women are
different by nature but in terms of
ruling who can be a ruler he sees no
difference between a man and a woman and
that they they are both fit for the role
I think even now most people aren't too
used to women being in a leadership but
again 2,000 years ago Socrates
recognized that there is no difference
which can be seen as a sort of
progressive thought to put forward
especially with the mind of how poorly
women were treated back in ancient Greek
I think they all they had to do was stay
at home all day taking care of the house
and they were generally treated poorly
as far as I know but then again you
could also just see it as recognizing
that women can get what men already have
so so who then are the most fit to rule
this city I'll let you get
that's right philosophers I gotta say
soccer today they're a little bit of an
elitist it really feels like
so since philosophers they seek truth
above all else and therefore their
rationale and their rational part of the
soul will ruled the city and best ruled
the city so Socrates has a very
interesting view of leadership which in
a way I agree with but it's also
extremely pessimistic he says that if
you look at how we determine a leader in
democracy it is a very long process to
go through with anyone that wants to
become a leader is up for a tremendous
task of going through a public election
it's not something that anyone is
willing to go through with to become a
leader in our democracy
you must truly want to become a leader
and Socrates argues that the one most
fitted to rule is the one that wants to
rule the least and he brings up this
example of a boat where a couple of
seamen or a couple of seafarers are on
this boat they're travelling to this
destination but everyone is arguing over
who should steer the ship was the one
who is most fit to steer the ship is the
one focusing on the Stars and they're
looking at the Stars to try and navigate
instead which is what they should be
doing so the person most fit to steer
the ship is the one focusing on what
they need to do to steer the ship
instead of arguing why they should steer
the ship I explained this very poorly
but I think you understand the point
therefore according to Socrates the one
who wants to rule the least isn't the
most appropriate to rule but they will
also never become the ruler because they
don't seek it and this is pessimistic in
the sense that it implies that the ship
cannot make it to the shore even if
people are arguing which is obviously
not the case next up we get into
metaphysics which I find a little hard
to understand still and therefore I will
try in my best
I do understand the allegory of the cave
and I think that's the probably the best
way to introduce the idea of the the
idea of the good as Socrates describes
it
Socrates recognizes the world as
something that can be described beyond
our senses he uses math as an example
2+2 will always be for no matter where
you are in the universe when certain
things according to our eyes and our
vision in our senses will appear
differently depending on our subjective
manners colors is something it's a color
red red for everyone you understand what
I mean
but 2+2 will always be for Socrates
brings up here in book 7 the most famous
metaphor in philosophy or Western
philosophy at least I talked about this
before on in my video and you might have
heard it already which is the famous
allegory of the cave
it's something that I discussed in my
simulacra and simulation video and I
used it in the context of simulation
which funny enough still applies but
Socrates brings up the allegory of the
cave as a way to describe education I
want you to try and imagine a very dark
cave and in this cave there are a couple
people in a row and these people are
completely immobilized they cannot move
any inch of their body that cannot move
their head imagine clockwork orange'
style strapped down to this in this cave
with chains the only thing these people
can see is the cave wall in front of
them now this wall has a bunch of
shadows cast upon them because there is
a light behind them and in front of this
light there are people crossing a bridge
so what the prisoners in the chains can
see on the wall are just shadows all
these people moving back and forth and
since these people have never
experienced anything else in their life
for them and what their senses are
telling them is that these shadows are
real because they don't know any other
truth so eventually in this allegory of
the cave one of the prisoners managed to
escape his chain
and his worldview is of course then
completely changed he sees people that
are real he sees a whole new dimension
essentially and so Kurtis describes this
experience as very painful something
very painful to go through but
eventually a satisfying experience but
he isn't the prisoner isn't completely
free yet and he managed to escape the
cave in itself where he eventually gets
blinded by the Sun again a very painful
experience but once it's calmed down he
sees he recognizes the Sun the light
brings all things into existence he sees
the flowers he sees the trees and
there's this beautiful image you can see
its character embrace praising the Sun
basically and this is the soccer this
metaphor for the idea of the good the
Sun bringing that the true forms see I'm
not really good at explaining it but
this the Sun represent the form of good
basically and the point of Education is
to drag a person out of this cave to see
things how they actually really are and
not just feeding information to you
not everyone can escape this cave and
therefore Socrates thinks that the
person who escaped the cave needs to
come back that philosopher-king needs to
come back from the cave to rule in book
eight Socrates steps back from
describing the the Republic of the city
and he instead takes some time to
describe different forms of regimes he
describes a democracy a an oligarchy
democracy and finally a tyranny and I
will kind of brush over this because I
don't know it that well and I kind of
want to say any form of time I have at
this point but I think what's important
here is how he notes that each one of
these different rulings are are worse
than the other and that in the last
stage which is when democracy the most
free form of city that there is will
eventually fall into tyranny that most
limited the least free city Socrates
says that the desire
or freedom will eventually lead to not
having proper rulers it will give the
chance for a tyrant to rise and I think
it's very very interesting how
accurately truckers test depicts the the
rise of the tyrant two thousand years
ago more than two thousand years ago he
accurately depicts something that has
already happened to as many times you
have the example of Saddam Hussein
Hussein who our last known tyrant who
rose to power through democracy I think
and he started off by doing a lot of
good for its people much like other
tyrants of our time Benito Mussolini for
example who famously made the trains run
on time
Saddam helped modernize infrastructure
he helped modernize industries health
care system education different social
services farming same with Hitler but I
will not bring up any examples because I
don't want to be taken out of context I
think you get the point the tyrant
starts from a democracy and and does
good for its people
but as Socrates describes the tyrant who
is ruled by its desires will eventually
get the taste of blood it will do
something to an opposition he will
execute one of its enemies and he will
do this in the name of the people he
will do it as I've done something to
protect you not me and once he had the
taste of blood that will just be the
start of it the tyrant who is ruled by
his lust and desires will not just bleed
the city dry but will become paranoid
and kill all their enemies this loss of
blood will continue only the people that
flatter the tyrant will will keep living
and anyone challenged in his position
will of course be executed and this is
what happened to Saddam assign a lot of
in the end of his regime his military
power was very poor because he had
executed anyone and most of his best men
just out of sheer paranoia Socrates
argues that the least happy man in the
world is this ruling tyrant
which actually starts to make a lot of
sense if you think about it constantly
living in this fear this paranoia driven
by your your greed and lust you can't
trust your friends
constant fear of enemies Saddam even
himself had to move where he lived every
single day to protect himself so not
only is the ruling tyrant the least
happy it's also the worst worse ruling
for a city for example Iraq used to be
so much richer before before the time
was saddam hussein and socrates draws
the the opposite line that the just man
is the happiest man and the unjust man
is the least happy man so then who is
the most happy man well of course you
could probably guess that's right the
philosopher everyone is anyone surprised
again such an elitist according to
Socrates the one seeking truth is the
greatest pleasure of them all and only a
philosopher will know this because he's
experienced all the pleasures it even
makes a really strange joke about it
saying that the philosopher king is 729
times more happier than the ruling
tyrant which obviously it's a joke
you cannot quantify such a thing I think
there's a reason behind the number I
just don't remember it let me know in
the comments Socrates also draws a
conclusion between the three parts of
the city at the three classes and the
three parts of the soul I cannot get
into it I'm sorry
I just remember it didn't really made
sense to me the idea of the soul from
Socrates but finally we made it to the
end book ten where Socrates brings up
the view of the afterlife he talks about
the myth of error which is a warrior who
died in battle and he then goes to the
afterlife with has a bunch of people in
it kind of like an airport and he sees
how the system works and basically
people will have to serve a thousand
years in heaven or a thousand years in
hell based on how you lived your life
that this is where you go but after
serving this thousand years you will
then get to pick a new life again and
here again according to Socrates only
this philosopher
know how to pick the right life I think
it's very interesting because just like
this natural progression of different
type of ruling so will the person the
individual go through the natural
progression between good and evil
themselves they will not always make the
right decision of what life they want to
live and only the philosopher knows
which life is the right choice and in
the story he will have to pick last I
don't know if Ava's error that had to
pick but the character of this myth has
to pick last between what life they can
live and he finds the life eventually
their life of what philosopher and he
says this is the life I would have
chosen even if I got to pick first and
he was not very happy with this decision
he picks this life of a philosopher an
ordinary man who Minds his own business
and that is the definition of justice
according to Socrates or Plato minding
your own business and not meddling with
other men's concerns I think I kind of
brushed over the end of how it all ties
in together with the individual and the
city but I think this has gone on well
enough
I think Plato's Republic is such a
phenomenal piece of literature it makes
me happy that I'm alive to even
experience it just from the sake of
taking part of these ideas that were
written so long ago I don't know what
else there exists anything like this the
life of Socrates is so interesting as
well and it continues in his other books
as well again this is why I'm so happy I
picked up literature because I think
it's so interesting to take part of
these discussion and ideas and and
stories whether you know it's real or
not I find it very very fascinating to
escape into I don't know what other
medium could possibly accomplish
something like this and I think Republic
is such a great example of that
it discusses ideas that are still very
much relevant today in a way that is
still very engaging and exciting and I
love reading this book I don't think I
would have taken so much time with it
otherwise and if you made it this far
thank you for watching it it wasn't
really much of a review
I got to bring up some of my thoughts
around it I would obviously give it 10
out of 10 I'll announce the next book
review in as always on Twitter or the
reddit and keep an eye for that I would
love to hear your thoughts and
discussion of the comments section or on
the reddit I'll see you guys there
good bye